et puis demain c'est le chanteur jean
ferrat qui sera l'invitée d'antenne 2010
il n'était pas apparu à la télévision
depuis plus de quatre ans sa rentrée
musicale est un événement autant par les
douze nouvelles chansons qu'ils viennent
enregistrer que par la reprise de tout
son répertoire depuis 20 ans retiré en
ardèche depuis plusieurs années à
l'écart des médias c'est pour antenne 2
et georges bégoux que jean ferrat a
rompu le silence en avant première c'est
en sa compagnie que je vous dit bonsoir
rebelles au pied grâce et remets ta
chérie
belle fille aussi
la série
et le temps passé c'est partir monde il
fallait que jean ferrat et des choses à
dire a chanté pour sortir du bois après
une longue absence et retrouver les
studios et se contraindre à 18 mois
d'enregistrement depuis sept ans la vie
à entraigues dans l'ardèche semblait lui
apporter davantage dans sa simplicité
que la pratique du spectacle d'une
manière qu'il est difficile de décrire
parce que on s'en aperçoit pas il ya
beaucoup de gens qui passent des amis il
ya beaucoup de distractions des vérités
il ya les pétanque
il ya déjà payant et à la pêche à la
truite au mode de jeu et puis à vos
activités au sein du conseil municipal
ou si je suis maire adjoint et et je
m'occupe alors je suis président du
comité des fêtes et puis je suis aussi
membre de la commission des travaux et
travaux
c'est une chose qui est très importante
et pour lesquelles on a beaucoup de mal
étant donné le peu de subventions qui
nous sont octroyés
l'une des dernières chansons de ferrat
fait déjà parler d'elle elle s'attaque
au bilan globalement positif des
soviétiques et dénoncent tous les
massacres toutes les couleuvres que les
staliniens ont voulu faire avaler que
vont en penser les amis communistes de
ferrat écoutez je ne sais pas j'écris
des choses que je sens que je crois être
vrai maintenant peut-être que ils sont
pas d'accord peut-être que certains ne
sont pas d'accord
avec ce que je chante c'est possible
mais je ne fais pas du tout nine antico
mise d'ailleurs le parti communiste bien
sûr ac a condamné compte en tout genre
le stalinisme et je crois pas que je
fasse autre chose dans cette chanson
une chanson politique cela fait toujours
de la presse mais il serait bien dommage
d'oublier pour cela que ferrat est aussi
le chanteur de l'amitié de la nature et
de l'amour comme en témoignent ses
couplets libertin que vous écoutez pour
la première fois pour pierre pc
qui peut tacher me
mais le fiancé l'amour et three
et le temps pressé c'est partie remise
pour aller danser la la la la la
autant qu'il nous sans robe raisonnable
griffon
nous irons ensemble au delà de tout
prête moi ta bouche
et vers un peu pour moi ta couche faire
pour l'amour de dieu
lallaing
le
laisse moi tranquille un peu
on ira jouer
août est ton absinthe war ton vin doux
au rire aux époux m
la fin complète s'édifie grasset
panama
la la